Rachel Lindsay thank you for joining us
there's so much to discuss with you so
it's hard to know where to start it's
been a lot these last few weeks The
Bachelor the greatest seasons ever show
premiered Monday night you wrote a blog
ahead of that on your website the first
question I would ask though is just
overall if you have a feeling or an
insight why do you think it's been this
long without a black lead in the male
bachelor franchise I want to make it
clear I say black because I'm black you
know I would like to see you know like
well there have been Latinos in the
league but you know Asian Indian I have
people reaching out to me from all
backgrounds ethnicities that are saying
they would like to see it and I think
that's the movement that you see going
on right now with the hashtag bi POC
Bachelor I honestly think that it's to
show us a business it's a franchise and
part of a business is giving you know
it's supply and demand it's giving them
what the supply that they want whether
they're demanding and I think they know
what they're on who their audience is
and what they want and so they're giving
them the product that they want which
are white leads and I don't think that
they've shied away from that at this
point I will say that when I was leave
they did make changes you know they
brought in producers of color that they
didn't work with me but they worked with
my contestants and I noticed that they
asked me a lot of questions because they
wanted to do things right because it was
the first time but after I was the lead
those changes went away and you only
have one black producer that's in the
house with the contestants and there
were three when I was there I definitely
talk to them about when are you going to
have a lead of color you know that you
have had several good candidates I named
them out in my blog post siente show
Mike Johnson you know before your
excuses used to be they don't make it
far enough you don't have you know
certain people trying out for the show
I've spoken to them about the lack of
minorities that try out to the show
and now you're getting that so now
what's the issue you know I think it
goes back to the business of it all
what's the response that you get when
you say those things to the higher-ups
that they want the everybody wants
diversity it's just it doesn't work out
it's kind of the answer that I'm given
we all want this to happen it's just for
one reason or another it doesn't happen
you know we can't have the perfect
bachelor or bachelorette and in the past
few seasons they haven't been stellar I
guess that's the best word that I can
use and so I'm just not sure that what
we're measuring it against as far as
what makes a good lead other than the
fact that you want to give the audience
what it is that they want which are
white leads I mean look at the Mike
Johnson conversation I think is the one
Pew hear from people the loudest when I
was watching hannasseys and I was
watching him in and saying Mike for
bachelor this guy's great and then the
conversation started to change and to be
honest I think it's hard because then
when Peters named Peter is half Latino
and so you think okay well this is this
is something but if you get specifically
into those why wasn't Mike Johnson the
bachelor did you ask that question did
anybody have a good answer for you
behind the scenes on that well it had a
good answer for me and I would also have
to clarify that Pete you know Juan Pablo
and Peter are Latino but they're white
Hispanic right their race is white we
haven't had one a person of color we
haven't had a black lead but I
definitely asked I was extremely vocal
about Mike Johnson and how he checked
all the boxes and it doesn't make sense
why he is not believed and even it
seemed as if the audience wanted him
the audience was my into Peter and
that's my also argument about the show
can make you fall in love with anyone
you know people weren't receptive to
Hannah brown then they loved her she's
the most popular by social media
standards in regards to the Bachelorette
Peter same thing they didn't love him
then they grew to love him you know as
he was molding into the bachelor
throughout his season at least is gonna
be getting part I just I don't know why
it wasn't my Johnson I don't know why it
wasn't seeing she's a Yale graduate
beautiful Taoiseach stunning made it to
the top three Eric made it to the top
three on my season you know it just it
all goes back to me to the same thing
you're just giving the audience what
they're comfortable with as a fan of the
show I don't want to believe that the
only reason Mike Johnson wasn't the
bachelor was because of his race it's
like I don't really well is that what
you believe right now no I don't believe
that I mean maybe it was a factor but
I'm not gonna say that they cuz I don't
know they do all kinds of background
checks and bet things out and maybe they
weren't I don't I have no idea what the
reason was but they have it I'm told
they have a reason cuz I definitely was
up in arms and I found that it wasn't
gonna be him I mean Mike aside I as you
mentioned it's been 24 seasons it's been
it's time it should have happened by
this point you also wanted to see the
franchise change the storylines for
people of color that you felt that they
were problematic I've seen you talk
before about your season and feeling
that way on your finale
I wondered if other examples had also
come to mind when you were writing that
yeah I mean I would say Jasmine during
Nick's season was you know the choking
and and like she just was very dramatic
look it plays into a certain stereotype
specifically when you don't have that
many people of color on the show and
you're highlighting them in a certain
way Eric was angry towards the beginning
of my season he was shown to be angry
Kenny was shown to be angry at the
beginning of my season and it played
into a stereotype that you have of black
men those definitely stand out something
I think when you have very few people of
color already on the show when you play
into certain stereotypes of them and
their stick their storylines it
perpetuates this thinking that the
audience already has for people of color
we were kind of brainstorming questions
and somebody from our online team said
did Claire season give her any hope did
the fact that there was a cry out for a
better age group and then Claire was
cast did ray give Rachel any hope about
change for the future it's a totally
different issue but I wonder did that
give you any hope you still want to see
them fulfill Claire season and if so
does that mean hitting a certain number
you know making the the cast a certain
percentage diverse does it mean adding
producers what would you like to see
them do and is what they should do going
with Claire season next oh I definitely
think they should move forward with
Claire season like my girl deserves to
find love she'd already be engaged right
now we hadn't been in the middle of a
pandemic you know like I talked to her
she's ready I think that it's
progression that they casted a lead
who's actually interested in dating
people outside of her race that's one
thing you can check as far as producers
I still think that they can bring in
more producers of color just to just to
even get a different perspective not
just so the contestants can feel
comfortable with but even on the casting
side so they can recruit more people of
color I think that that's huge have you
heard from anybody on the executive side
the show's creator and executive
producer since that blog yesterday Oh
since the blog no I haven't heard from
anyone in the past week
yes I have heard from an executive
producer just saying that they hear me
and they want to make changes this isn't
my first rodeo with hearing an executive
producer say I want to we want to make
some changes I believe you want to but
or I used to believe you want to but I'm
not seeing anything I've been affiliated
with strangers for almost four years and
I hear you but I'm not seeing any action
behind those words I would never tell
people to boycott the show because I
truly believe there are great people
behind the camera and I still have great
relationships with those people to this
day
I just think it's a business it's the
franchise and you want to put out a
product that you know is going to be
well received you know it and it's
worked for you for 18 years so why would
you change it I think that's the
motivation now you said that if this
doesn't change you plan to disassociate
from the franchise you and Becca kufran
have that podcast Bachelor happy hour
that that is through Warner Brothers
what does that actually look like I am
under contract right now so I'm not
quite sure how that's going to work but
I'm serious I it's more of when I say
I'm stepping away yes I said I'm
stepping away because I'm embarrassed
and I just don't want to be affiliated
with in these times right now I feel
like we all are self reflecting on have
you been an ally what what are you
affiliated with it is part of the
problem you know different you know
you're just you're just looking within
during these times and as I look with
then I look at my affiliation with the
Batchelor franchise and what's wrong and
I did find it frustrating I got a lot of
negative feedback where there were those
who maybe are new to following me that
are saying why are you just now saying
something which is why my article I laid
out I've always been extremely vocal and
it hasn't always been well-received
now it's we're living in different times
so it's received in a different way but
I don't want to be affiliated with a
franchise who's not on the right side of
this at this time at this point you
can't be neutral you're either on the
wrong side or the right side and the
franchise to me has been on the wrong
side for 18 years for 40 seasons so are
you going to step on to the right side
at this point and that's what I am
trying to put the pressure on them to do
and hoping also that the audience will
as well I have talked to some producers
but I've said I was going to leave if
they don't make changes so it's
conditional so I'm waiting to see what
changes are made to date they haven't
made any type of statement statement
which baffles me so many companies have
made statements in regard to what's
happening in our country and I thought
oh for sure we'll get it before the
greatest seasons air
and we haven't but I feel like it's
coming so I'm trying to be patient and
wait and give them an opportunity to
respond and see how they respond and
then I'll make my decision after that I
agree with you I've been baffled as well
that there hasn't been a network or show
or company statement in some way I was
wondering have you told them I need to
see these specific things happen for me
to stay I mean definitely we need to see
a lead of color in the role for season
25 I said that last year after Mike
Johnson was not cast I was so I don't
think I'm still old for that so as much
as I like Peter he's a delight I still
think I'm over Mike Johnson not being
picked as the bastard but I didn't lay
it out that way
Garrett was someone who came under fire
for the content that he'd liked on
social media have you and Becca had that
conversation again with all of this
happening yes
Becca not podcast about Tuesday morning
and I we discuss his recent post and I
was very honest with her I said Becca I
never publicly spoke about his
problematic social media behavior out of
respect for you I really like Becca we
had a relationship and I care about her
but seeing what he did with the with the
thin blue line post which basically is
blue lives matter I was very vocal with
her about how that made me feel about
how you know fool me once shame on you
fool me twice shame on me
this is who I feel he is and it's it's
upsetting to me because I've been around
him and I've spent time with them and
I've really grown to like him but it's
like 15 steps back after what I just saw
with this post and even more so he's
doubled down on the way that he feels
and I just told her it's for me this is
just a person who's not willing to
unlearn the way that he has grown up the
society that he has lived in and because
he hasn't really been around people of
color which she admitted to and we go
into detail about it on the podcast but
that is one of the things that is
frustrating to me as well because
this is now the second incident that we
know of where he's done something like
this or he's shown his hand how do you
just feel emotionally at this point
about being a voice for change to
someone who you're employed by and
having to navigate this complicated in
some ways empower in some ways volatile
time it is a lot and that's overwhelming
and it's heavy I mean I even took a
break
I had just podcasted with Becca about
the whole Garrett situation it was just
a lot and so I really am big on
meditation and rate and journaling and
taking time for myself and so I've done
that so that I can regroup and move
forward because I feel like I'm not
doing this for me at this point I've
gotten all I can out of the franchise
right I've become the Bachelorette I've
gotten married you know there's really
nowhere else for me to go unless they
try to make me a producer a consultant I
totally would be because I would be
doing it for other people to have a good
experience because I overall had a good
experience as the Bachelorette I'm
thinking of Peter season because even
though it was Peters bachelor I remember
when that season came out there were
headlines where there was talk about oh
but this cast does look fairly diverse
this cast maybe looks better than it has
in the past
are there any initiatives behind the
scenes for we will be trying to make
this cast more diverse we will be doing
these things or has it never been
something you've heard talked about
that's what I've heard the most we're
trying to make the cast more diverse
we're trying to make the gap that is the
one thing out of everything that I've
heard them say and you have seen it more
diverse and it's great for that first
picture that first night when everyone's
standing in the mansion and you can see
all the different races and ethnicities
represented in that one picture but if
you don't cast a lead who is genuinely
into dating outside of their race and
open to a new experience and has done it
before then by the time you get to the
second half of the season it looks
nothing like that picture and that's my
big issue - you don't
asked people who were genuinely into
dating outside of their race that's a
question that they asked you during
casting are you open to dating you know
what's your type what do you like or you
open the dating outside of your race
everybody says yes who would say no I
don't know the casting process and the
questions you guys are asked is it that
questions need to be asked like have you
dated people outside of your race and
does that question need to be given more
weight I think it does because I if I
remember correctly it was are you
interested in get you know like would
you would you be open to dating someone
outside of your races if it's a new
experience like being the bachelor the
Bachelorette and of course you're like
yeah I mean that sounds interesting but
as you see and I'll give Peters season
as news/peter season as an example
Natasha made it to the what top six or
seven but she never had a one-on-one
date until the end and when he takes her
on the one-on-one date he sends her home
you know in Hannah's season Mike Johnson
was the last person of color he gets a
one-on-one date and he gets in home
and it's very evident that they're more
there to fill a spot than they are to
genuinely pursue a relationship with
that contestant and the audience calls
it out every single time you mentioned
to your your response when that 2019
Bachelorette reunion was filmed and that
you pointed out that you were the only
woman of color in the room I was
actually emotional I don't even think
I've ever talked about this I was
emotional the day of the 15 year reunion
because I felt so out of place and and
it's not that the girls weren't
welcoming I mean we have a group chat we
talk all the time we've had snooze
during quarantine I glad that I went
because it really it was really great to
meet bachelorettes I hadn't before and
to create the sisterhood but it was
emotional for me I remember they had to
redo my makeup because I was just kind
of like this is so sad that one one out
of fifteen even but Hannah wasn't there
and one out of fifteen and it just was
so it just hit me in a certain way to
realize this is what the franchise's
this is representative of the franchise
I'm affiliated with and I don't know if
any changes being made to try to change
so I I have spoken with producers and I
did after that and then of course it was
we want to do better we want more leaves
of color but then no action has been
taken
I mean I've even been vocal in saying
though they're not gonna have you know
when when Taoiseach was up when CN was
up they thought they said oh do you
think we're gonna get a black bass rap
and I said no it's too soon we're not
gonna have it back-to-back and I mean
let's be honest my season had lower
ratings I don't know if it was the
lowest but it was definitely one of the
low lower rated seasons and that was
reflective of who the audience was so I
think they know who their audience is it
is a business and you know they're
catering to their viewers what how do
you kind of think you will look back at
your experience with The Bachelor
because it was a jumping-off point for
you to achieve some dreams that you've
worked hard for but at the same time
there were issues with it yeah I think
that and it changed The Bachelor changed
my life completely I'm married my career
path has changed I've made friends
lifelong friends behind the camera some
on the camera with some of the women I
will never forget the experience at the
bachelors giving me and that's why it's
always been hard for me because you
never want to bite the hand that's
feeding you so I'm very grateful and I
acknowledge that what the franchise has
given me but at the same time I have to
be true to myself and hold them
accountable when I feel like they're
doing something wrong so from here how
critical are these next few days and
what do they look like I am expecting
something in the next week but it'll be
at least a couple months before we hear
anything about a lead of color being
announced so I'm waiting to see what
internal changes are made at this point
what I'm doing is for people who look
like me for other for people of
different backgrounds ethnicities I feel
like I'm fighting this fight for them
and their place on the show and I'm very
big on if you have a platform you should
use it I hate the term in
Lewin sir but if I'm going to be labeled
as an influencer let me influence things
in the right direction
and in the right way let me not just be
selling things and posting pretty
pictures you're giving your platform for
purpose and for a reason and I want to
use mine in the right way so that's why
as exhausted as I may be at times I mean
I look totally tired right now even the
lashes aren't healthy as exhausted as I
as I feel I have to remember the reason
behind it thank you so much for taking
the time to do this and you do not look
as tired as you think I was literally
thinking blowing thanks for having me